distinguished guests friends of the
University of Oslo it's a great pleasure
to welcome you to the University of to
the University I belong after an
emotional weekend most of you followed
yesterday's strong Nobel Peace Prize
ceremony it was touching to hear Award
winner sets coeternal testify about her
own experiences on August 6 1945 about
losing clothes family as a 13 year old
watching human suffering closely how the
radiation affected both those that
experienced radiation directly and the
generations that followed a strong and
clear time witness we need time
witnesses and this Allah and the
neighboring vessel has frequently been
used to witness both past and present
this fall on September 1st just mean
barriers received an honorary Doctorate
at this stage barriers fight corruption
organized crime and drug trafficking as
well as the many human rights violations
that occurred during Guatemala's 36 year
civil war on November 13th East I guess
I didn't received the University of Oslo
human rights price a Turkish academic
and human rights campaigner she was not
allowed to travel to - from Turkey it
was present by escaped Skype giving
strong evidence of the situation in
Turkey today on November 26th guided
Gollum back and life gurus witnessed
about the situation in Norway 75 years
earlier a day when 529 Jews were
deported from Oslo transported by the
ship do now and later sent on to us
which lost Saturday December 9th we met
a delegation with survivors from
Hiroshima and Nagasaki in our Botanical
Gardens
they brought seeds from trees that
survived the atomic bump in 45 seeds
that symbolize survival power and hope
today we are again assemble here in this
splendid oblong a place that has been of
large importance to the cultural and
intellectual life in Orvis since it was
inaugurated in 1911 it has been and
still is a central meeting place in the
region cultural and public life and in
fact the Nobel Peace Prize was awarded
in this very Hall from 1947 until 1989
we are pleased that the University of
Oslo can serve society by cooperating
across sectors and by being an arena for
dialogue academia stroll in society is
to encourage deeper understanding
critical thinking and free speech which
is why dialogue indeed is so important
I'm looking forward to the new Nobel
Peace Prize for him here today across
dividing lines and I would like to
express my sincere gratitude to the
DeNoble Institute for the cooperation
and I will now give the word two Nobel
Institute's director who love gemstones
please
good morning this year's Nobel Peace
Prize forum Oslo across dividing lines
will address indigenous peoples rights
within the context of social justice and
environmental protection it is indeed a
timely issue first 2017 marks both the
20th anniversary or the adoption of the
UN declaration on the rights of
indigenous peoples and the 25th
anniversary of dr. Rigoberta menchú
receiving the Nobel Peace Prize in
recognition of her work for peace and
reconciliation across ethnic cultural
and social dividing lines still 25 years
later across today's world the rights of
indigenous peoples are frequently being
challenged disputed neglected this is
why the organizers of the forum has
decided to invite dr. Rigoberta menchú
back to Oslo to reflect upon the state
of affairs concerning indigenous rights
twenty-five years after her Nobel Peace
Prize award what progress has been made
and what are the unsolved issues and
pressing challenges ahead immediately
following dr. Manchus talk a six-member
panel will discuss the Standing Rock
conflict in North Dakota where oil
pipeline interests have clashed with the
rights of the Dakota Lakota Nakota
peoples and compare it to some extent
within this year
mine controversy in the municipality or
Carlson in northern Norway a conflict
affecting the indigenous Sami population
of the region the panel discussion will
be moderated by fred de sam lazaro
highly respected correspondent for PBS
newshour
one of the most trusted news broadcasts
in the United States as the theme across
dividing lines suggests this year's
Nobel Peace Prize forum Oslo is intended
not only to shed light upon the
conflicts and interests at stakes in
these conflicts but also to provide a
platform for dialogue and experience
shearing shearing on behalf of the noble
Institute I would like to express my
gratitude to our partner the University
of Oslo and your sponsors and events
partners new generation power and peace
through Commerce for their generous
support but now ladies and gentlemen it
is my great honor to introduce one of
the great champions for Indonesia's
indigenous peoples rights over the last
30 years a Nobel Peace Prize laureate of
1992 dr. Rigoberta menchú please take
the floor
[Applause]
good morning placer estar aquí ellos lo
SLE Brando esta grandia Ignacio
calendario Maya sturdy generations and
what it does remind us is that we are
just one generation and that tomorrow we
will also be grandmothers and
grandfathers of this planet and
therefore our ancestors remind us that
we have to open a path for the new
generations so that they can continue
their full lives
the grandfathers and grandmothers have
allowed us to have our grandmother moon
the grandmothers of the water
the grandfather trees the grandfather
animals these are the grandfathers and
grandmothers that give life to this
planet I do hope that you have your
earphones on are you listening are you
hearing okay good
okay we'll give people time to put their
headsets on I would like to express my
deep gratitude particularly to the Nobel
Institute and the Nobel Committee for
inviting me it is a great homage to the
indigenous peoples it's a great homage
to a laureate to the price that we
received 25 years ago and during these
25 years it is true that many things
have happened events that on the one
hand allow us to visualize the steps
that have been taken particularly in the
area of indigenous peoples rights we see
a lot of results from the work done by
our sisters and brothers in the work
group on indigenous peoples in the UN
and the World Conference in Vienna we
saw lots of results of their in
participation in the General Assembly in
New York where the permanent forum of
indigenous peoples was created we should
also recall 100 v-i hundred and 69
convention and the declaration of ended
in his people's rights
these have set a very special agenda for
the indigenous peoples and for
governments we have seen over the past
years lots of debate in the
international forest about indigenous
peoples this is positive because 25
years ago we didn't have these
instruments at the international level
we didn't have a Special Rapporteur on
indigenous peoples
no meetings and summits within the
United Nations but also 25 years ago we
were discussing whether within the Peace
Accords particularly the Guatemalan
Peace Accords there should be a chapter
on indigenous peoples rights and after
long debates we achieved some agreements
that particularly emphasize indigenous
peoples rights so if we talk about these
rights we could start with the
references in the international field
particularly in the United Nations and
in some scenarios within the
Organization of American States but we
can also see the inter-american Human
Rights contributions there are series of
resolutions on indigenous peoples
particularly if we talk about land
rights and the effects of extractive
policies that have deeply affected
indigenous peoples they I know before
the inter-american Court of Human Rights
within the oh yes there is a discussion
on an American Convention on the Rights
of Indigenous Peoples we're part of this
dynamic 25 years ago we saw the
beginning of 169 Convention and today we
see the fruits it is because of the
debate and the discussions that have
produced these results this is very
positive also at the national level
there are many what progress made
particularly in terms of the specific
rights of indigenous peoples in
Guatemala we achieved that the 23 Mayan
languages are now official languages so
in the eyes of the law we are now 23
language Mayan language we also have
other mechanisms instituted to monitor
indigenous peoples participation so
there is a very important legislative
agenda both at the national and
international level and i remember that
at that time there was a lot of
attention paid to the plans within the
UN to integral developments achievement
and this included also the indigenous
peoples so this is a group of
instruments that we now have achieved
now reality also has a different angle
over these past 25 years we see that
there a large number of indigenous
languages that are no longer spoken
they're lost they never had the
opportunity to develop their languages
over these past 25 years we see that
there is also a percentage of the
ancestral lands that are lost to a great
degree as a result of discrimination
plunder and the result of the lack of
public policies in the countries where
there are indigenous populations there
is a very important international
progress but at the national level there
is a very worrisome situation we see
many of the indigenous peoples are
slowly abandoning their lands and
they're losing their connection to a
great ancestral civilization in some
cases it is because their lands are
forcefully taken from them in other
cases it's because of lack of work
particularly in the urban areas we see
an enormous gap between the definition
of the rights of indigenous peoples and
the fulfillment of public policies that
would benefit indigenous peoples at the
center of the problems at least in all
of Latin America we find land issues
land is still the fundamental problem of
the one hand States did not give deeds
and titles to the indigenous communities
and the other hand extraction of natural
resources that belong to indigenous
peoples create new conflicts
particularly the collision with some
transnationals that irresponsibly
exploit mother earth in these situations
are found in more in some countries than
in others in Guatemala I still consider
that the biggest problems of the coming
years will be land mineral extraction
particularly because the communities do
not benefit from the development that is
being presented to the country
the problem is that the main point of
resources that states assign to
education by bilingual education and
culture very often trickles away into
corruption and corruption hampers it's
getting to the indigenous people so we
see on the one hand that the indigenous
peoples rights in their everyday life
faced great challenges and difficulties
there are much abuse particularly we see
in many cases that the criminalization
of the indigenous leaders continues but
on the other hand we see that we have
instruments so what should we do
probably revitalize an agenda a new
agenda for the coming years particularly
to find the mechanisms that will allow
us to apply the regulations in to the
public policies of states and active a
proactive participation on the part of
indigenous peoples this is a demand that
we have been presenting over the past
three decades where we have wanted to
build a route that's shared between the
National States and the indigenous
communities and their leaders convention
169 has been one of the most cited
conventions by indigenous peoples in the
past 25 years in some countries we had
to fight to make the application of the
convention real and official in - and
incorporated into our constitutions in
other countries convention 169 is
now an instrument which is well suited
and used by the indigenous peoples who
have held this series of hearings among
the population in the framework of this
convention now some of them are not
finding but they are hearings and
consultations that are legitimate
because the indigenous peoples
participate in Guatemala we have had 72
popular hearings in the framework of
convention 169 the immense majority of
the population vote together with the
local authorities in favour of a hearing
which would be a fully informed
consultation but they also vote in favor
of no extraction of minerals with
methods that harm and injure Mother
Earth or destroy life with chemicals or
other types of minerals that do not
bring development to the indigenous
peoples we have wanted to find and
identify models for example the for the
use of hydroelectric developments to our
benefit but many of the models that we
have is that you see the electric grid
close to the village but there's no line
into the village so therefore we often
see that the confrontations are becoming
more intense but I am an optimistic
woman I think that if we 25 years ago
did not have the declaration of
universal principles on the rights of
indigenous peoples we didn't have the
experience that the permanent forum in
the United Nations means
nor did we have the opportunity of a
special rapporteur we didn't have direct
participation of indigenous peoples in
many of the negotiating rounds around
the world so we can now reap the
benefits of this experience for future
generations we are a generation that
lived the Cold War the most cruel
violence in our families and in our
homes and today there are many
opportunities and we will not allow this
type of violence again in our
communities but I see more experience in
Latin America because the indigenous
peoples have been part of this
convulsive past and the convulsive
political decisions in our region and I
am sure that there is now a group of
indigenous leaders that are taking the
responsibility of charting the course we
hope that this forum will call on the
international community to continue to
support indigenous leaders wherever they
are in their fight for their rights it
is necessary to support the work of
indigenous leaders male and female
because their struggle is nothing but
supplementary to the road to the future
in these 25 years I have seen that the
Nobel Peace Prize was a deep recognition
of the rights and the struggle and the
tenacity of the indigenous peoples
it means a recognition of the indigenous
peoples wherever they are but it also
means a recognition of their thinking
the technology the contributions to
humanity a support to the future of the
hopes of the suffering and pain of the
indigenous peoples the Nobel Peace Prize
also represented a very strong blow to
racism and discrimination worldwide the
Peace Prize turned the world's eyes on
the indigenous peoples not free but erm
and true but the community of indigenous
people so we're proud of this award
because we believe that it set a
historic precedent that it underlines
the importance of the voice and world of
indigenous peoples and also the concern
in the UN to identify these mechanisms
that have already mentions for the
coming years the indigenous peoples will
still need to develop a shared agenda
between the international community the
UN and the indigenous peoples I would
like to pay homage to the Norwegian
development assistance the Nordic
countries have been very present in all
of the processes that we've been through
and I have seen that with my own eyes
that in Latin America what Amala our
progress is thanks to the cooperation
from the Nordic countries Sweden in
particular has invested a lot of effort
in accompanying the indigenous peoples
us has no way we hope that no way we
will continue to be the
of a sunray that will fall upon the
indigenous peoples the recognition of
their leaders and the accompanying of
their tireless struggle we would also
like to pay homage to the incredible
example that the Peace Prize represents
a support for women's struggle women
have had a tremendous participation in
many fields and thanks to this base we
would like to also bring to the fore for
young because the young not only need
land and full participation but they
also need knowledge they need to widen
their leadership a leadership for peace
because they will replace us these three
issues I think are fundamental for this
forum the recognition of the instruments
the recognition of a reality that makes
deep impact in the indigenous peoples
that keep living in silence and the
recognition of our youth and their role
in the future we have felt accompanied
throughout the struggles of all
indigenous peoples and therefore I would
like to pay homage to our brothers that
worked tirelessly over the past 25 years
we have also achieved a level of
participation and the political arenas
and this level of political
participation is an example of that it
is possible to find a common path with
all human beings on the planet that in
particular without
the citizens of the countries where we
live and work every day education for
peace is another of our demands we want
the indigenous peoples also to be
guaranteed their own peace and harmony
based on the deepest legacy that we have
from our ancestors which is the
plenitude of life and we fight and
struggle for this plenitude of life
thanks to all the friends that I see in
the room here thanks to you
also we have had success with the
indigenous agenda it is a reality
despite restrictions and problems and
limitations we have success we have a
guide we have an example to lead us into
the future
I hope for this forum the best
conclusions and that there will be
follow-up we have come here to look for
an agenda that consecutive agenda that
can be achieved and I'm sure that we can
continue to exchange and I'm quite sure
that our ancestral authorities and
leaders can also lead us they have now
strengthened their participation in our
countries and the teaching of the new
generations this is what will make it
possible and has made it possible to be
here that the world cultures live live
ancestral traditions live our languages
and no human relations in harmony and
brotherhood
and with Mother Earth as I started today
our holiday reminds us that we are but a
few generations that now inhabit the
planet and it depends
on us what kind of planet we will leave
to future generations and what would be
better than starting today to work with
those who will take over after us many
things have happened in these 25 years
but there has been no other indigenous
receiving representative receiving the
Nobel Peace Prize I hope there will be
other kin deters but I would like to
express my thanks to the noble Institute
and committee for this opportunity after
being awarded the Peace Prize - that is
they I can and also the indigenous
peoples I think these two awards both
honor the struggle of the indigenous
peoples I would like to express my
thanks to the Norwegian people for their
love and their caring your only bail is
6 million but despite that through the
memory of Alfred o noble you have made a
great contribution to universal harmony
I hope you will continue on that path
building universal harmony thank you
[Applause]
please
we'd like to invite our panelists to
kindly take their seats and would also
like to invite up to the podium here
elder Tim Mintz two leaders leaders in a
brief prayer you see here
I want to offer something that is gonna
take you back to my homeland the
indigenous nations of the Lakota Dakota
Dakota and do that sharing a part we
offer prayer that the Great Spirit will
listen to us that he will have pity on
us and the things that we're gonna talk
about today I'm a touch back on my
homeland of Canada North Dakota
understanding Rock reservation so my
relatives asked me to offer this and I
offer it in great humbleness to the
Sammis indigenous people of this land of
all the indigenous people that are
within this great halls here but also to
my relatives I want to say it in my way
also so I ask for forgiveness if you
don't understand cochinita wanna their
tacos annihilation hominy fetching our
government occasion um knowledge da
cunha mustache - hatred production work
on hatred a bedazzler top who openly
what corner Hatcher who Gaddafi hatred
to caution or not they work on tequila
how about you you know code to connect
him to one that didn't know what country
tacos in accommodation National who
succeed actually he's now tsukishima you
know who Sheila for a honey no gosh you
know oh yeah yeah when she no no no no
no she
[Music]
Oh
the cosmos hey they're not that she
knows you know she don't know me trust
you know who should clean and attention
here it's okay ochio no syllable no so
am I here homie talk to you I see thank
you
thanks very much for the invitation to
be here Orlov thank you Dr Manchu so
many notable people here so many notable
people here so little time so I will
abbreviate or actually skipped most of
the formal introductions if you need to
know more about our panelists there's
abundant material on the Internet
perhaps it's enough in your in your
brochures I was asked to begin with a
few words of background to guide our
discussion today trying to narrow a vast
vast topic that dates back centuries and
I started to wonder on my first visit to
Norway from where I live in Minnesota
what might have happened if Christopher
Columbus had managed somehow to consult
with Leif Ericson it might have pointed
him in a different direction
because he was looking for Indians from
my homeland he wound up in the wrong
hemisphere and found some different
people that he called Indians anyway and
it was the start of a yawning divide
between indigenous communities in the
nation states that emerged on their
lands and it's a divide of course that
is not restricted to the new world as
we'll discuss later today today we'll
visit two very distinct theaters in this
divide to see if there are lessons to be
learned one from the other
or just globally and for those of you
not familiar I will add just a paragraph
each on the two cases that we're going
to be talking about today from which we
have several of the principles the
Dakota access pipeline straddles four
states from the Bakken oil fields of
North Dakota to Illinois for policy
makers who support it the project has
created thousands of construction jobs
about 40 permanent ones and fits with a
goal of US energy independence
construction of this pipeline was slowed
for months and years by protesters from
the Standing Rock Lakota community and
hundreds of sympathizers protesting a
pipeline that came very very close to
the main water supply source of this
community and protesting as well the
decimation of many sacred sites and
artifacts the resistance often met with
a harsh crackdown and at least one of
our panelists can attests to that
firsthand things seesawed through the
court and regulatory systems until they
screeched to a very abrupt halt after
November's election oil began flowing
through that pipe in June the other case
takes us to the northern Finnmark region
of norway where the new seed company is
all I've mentioned is proposing a copper
mine on lands inhabited by the sami
people the sami parliament has opposed
the project concerned about the impact
on reindeer husbandry a traditional Sami
occupation there are also environmental
concerns about the plan to bury mined
wastes in a fjord that's critical to
salmon fisheries this project has also C
sought for years between a Norwegian
government that has largely approved it
and the regional Finnmark Council which
sees it as an economic stimulus for a
region that needs one but continued
opposition from the Sami Parliament more
deliberations are likely so let's go to
our panel which is not representative of
all sides of the conflict the organizers
told me this is just not practical or
possible for a number of reasons and in
any event the purpose here is not to
relitigate these cases in each of the
disputes even though our panel is hardly
agree with one another in many cases but
rather in pursuit of crossing the divide
I want to go first to Grand Chief Edward
John
of the last in community in Canada
you've worked globally with the United
Nations and forging and indigenous
rights to self-determination it would
seem that the ground reality the
economic imperatives are just simply
overwhelming in such cases and the
outcome pretty much the same whether
it's in the US or in Norway which have
very different systems so like I have a
two-part question to start us out where
do you see hope for self-determination
and specifically what is it that
indigenous communities are specifically
seeking as the outcome in cases such as
this thank you firstly your Highnesses
and all friends here
to my fellow panelists I wanted to thank
my sister regu Berta for the beautiful
words that she shared with us today and
I think she laid for us a very important
groundwork and what you did 25 years ago
and and today as well I want to
acknowledge your son's 23rd birthday
today mash congratulations
so regret I talked about their youth and
there's a young lady her name is Anna
here she's the the Chiefs personal
assistant today she volunteered we're
talking about our youth and how
important we hold them up and we cherish
them and the future belongs to them as
we wind our way through through our own
respective lives and and so today I want
to say that I am from Canada where
hockey is king or queen and I do you
know about Mats Zuccarello from this
land here
very good hockey player playing for the
wrong team the New York Rangers he
should be playing for Vancouver our
sister brought up the issue of dizziness
languages and she is right the United
Nations former secretary-general ban
ki-moon said every every week the two
weeks one indigenous language dies and
that's that's a very hard fact to
undertake in in the country where I come
from our language is forbidden our
children including myself were removed
from our families from our communities
from our lands from our elders we were
brought into these institutions called
Indian Residential schools and we were
to be assimilated we were supposed to be
the instruments of our own demise that
we were to be assimilated the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission which
concluded its final report in 2015 in
Canada came to one fundamental truth one
fundamental conclusion that Canada's
laws policies practices amounted to
cultural genocide this is in a developed
country but that's a history at the last
hundred fifty years I'll come back to
that in terms of the hope crossing
crossing the divide the divide firstly
is historical it is very deep
as my sister Rigoberto mentioned is
marred with assimilation its marked with
colonialism its marked with massacres
its marked with genocide its marked with
slavery and we it is our history we've
lived through that and today the
implications of the historical
relationships remain and so we find our
communities in a very dire situation
where social economic disparities are
very deep compared to the rest of the
population so we are working to find and
to work on solutions so we're looking at
this divide I was honored to witness the
ceremonies yesterday because there there
was discussion about another divide
between humanity and States between
States themselves in the situation of
indigenous peoples were talking about
the divide between the state and
indigenous peoples so there are
similarities the UN declaring the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
adopted in 1948 was in response to some
serious human rights violations and so
in nineteen 2007 seventy years later the
Universal Declaration of the Rights of
Indigenous Peoples was adopted and it's
a framework for building peace building
relationships and so I want to give an
example of Canada where when the United
Nations Declaration was completed that
the Human Rights Council in Geneva in
2006 the 48th member states voted and
Canada was a member then and Canada
voted no along with Russia the Russian
Federation I was there I was I was
heartbroken and so it went to New York
in 2007 the United Nations General
Assembly voted again and the board at
the General Assembly turned green there
were four red dots United States
Australia New Zealand and Canada aborted
no
and we were heartbroken again that our
own country would have bought it know
that these were developed states with
relationships with indigenous peoples so
we went to work back in Canada today
Canada has adopted under this new
government the United Nations
declaration without qualifications and
now there is a bill before the House of
Commons to to give life to the bill to
the to the declaration by legislation
and so we find ourselves in a place of
optimism that we will begin to address
the disparities that do exist the
biggest conflict we find are in relation
to the rights to self-determination in
article three of the Declaration and the
rights to lands territories and
resources from articles 26 to 32 and
they I the concept of free prior
informed consent where there is
development to happen in our respective
territories so I had the honor of
visiting my sister's territories last
year a year ago and did a report for the
United Nations permanent forum and what
I witnessed and she's in a way better
position than I am to tell that stories
I wanted to to lay out that framework
that the Universal Declaration and the
rights of indigenous peoples is the
centerpiece now for all indigenous
peoples we work to over 27 years to get
that declaration in place it is also
ours we cherish it and we want the
states to work with us to implement it
the United Nations decorative United
Nations has developed has a system-wide
action plan where the declarations
embedded in the Paris agreement
sustainable development 20 plus 30 goals
and but there's a flaw in the uptake at
the state level at the country level and
so maybe I will leave it at at that
point thank you Fred the second part of
my question because I think that's going
to be a theme which is specifically what
outcomes
our indigenous communities seeking but
you've you've set the the broad sort of
agenda for us today talking about having
a framework in place to acknowledge
self-determination the devil is in the
details and the implementation which is
going to be another theme and the United
States did come around to signing
signing after initially saying no but it
didn't seem to matter to you Holyoke
Lafferty you were on the front lines in
the Dakota access pipeline controversy
where at Standing Rock and you have the
bruises physical and otherwise to show
for it and I'm just wondering now that
you know essentially oil is flowing
where do you go from here and what
energizes you to continue where you're
going is it's not all over I assume you
go from here
tell us what all of the chief just told
matters when it comes to put you know it
didn't seem to matter how make you happy
hey Kaka walk are we in my chippy my
name is Holyoke Lafferty I am miniconjou
Oglala and suitengu Lakota
I am of the Oh Chet Isha Conley sacred
fires I am very honored to be here today
and I and I'm grateful that you're all
here to hear the words that were
speaking and the stories that we have to
share I am one of over 800 people who
were brutalized and arrested during the
Standing Rock resistance and I am one of
thousands of others who just stood
together who were able to listen and and
heed the call of our hearts to unity we
heard the cry of the earth of the water
and we decided that we were willing to
put everything else aside because we
want life for the water we
life for the earth we want life for our
future generations so back to the
question here if you could redirect me
the hole that propels you in this battle
it would seem to the outside world was
lost if what we were trying to do is
redirect that pipeline it is where it
was intended to be definitely but you
have no intention to move on with
different pursuits of your life this is
a very central concern what gives you
hope that will continue to propel you
forward what gives what gives me hope is
that I am one of so many people we have
endured over 500 years of genocide our
preceding generations have experienced
so much trauma the government has come
they have stolen our children they have
stolen attempted to steal our culture
they have stolen our language they have
tried to kill the Indian in us we have
lived through generations of hopeless
situations where other people on the
outside looking in with things that were
insane for having hope that we continue
to carry on I can't explain to you why
or how but this is just the way that
we're made as indigenous people I can
say you know as the women of the nations
you know when we have our we see our
children that are afraid that are that
are fearful we're afraid to but we dig
deep and we find that hope we find a way
to provide inspiration for our people to
continue to carry forward the fight that
we have no other option we are the life
givers we're are the protectors of the
life for our children and our
grandchildren in all future generations
so
there is no other way but to find hope
so so for me it's it's a way of being
it's you know it's a way that it's just
the way that we are we it's who we are
to find hope so so right now at this
moment in history we are living
prophecies being fulfilled we have been
told have had these teachings passed
down in our tribes and our communities
in our circles and you know we may not
share all of the details of those
prophecies a lot of them are known
pretty publicly but you know there are
other parts that as indigenous people we
have to you know protect the sacredness
of those things but we are living right
now the prophecies that have been
foretold and I believe that each of us
that are alive on this earth at this
moment in time we're here for a reason
we are all a part of this prophecy we
all have a responsibility to stand up to
have courage and to just do our part in
this big story of evolution the earth is
suffering the water is suffering our
people have suffered for so long but I
believe that we are in a time now that
we have the opportunity for a change and
and this has all been this is all bigger
than us it's bigger than any of us
humans so you know I I stand just as a
servant to this prophecy to do what my
I'm responsible for as a look like a
woman and I see all of my brothers and
sisters globally doing the same thing
Stephanie Hope Smith you offered your
services as a conduit if you will go
between you have seen the pain they
divide the deficit and trust the fact
that communities that live very close to
one another are very foreign to one
another on either side of this divide
what tools did you bring in what were
your goals
in the work that you did in this in this
particular and you know Dakota Pipeline
controversy well good morning to
everyone and to what a distinguished
group of people in the room today so I I
greet Udall so my name is Stephanie and
I speak as myself
um I don't represent any organization I
am NOT a government employee I'm clearly
not indigenous but what I've discovered
in my spirit is that there is a place
for people who can come in and be
neutral it doesn't mean that their heart
is neutral because mine is not but to
choose to be neutral in a moment to
hopefully bring people together to work
through questions often that role is
holding up a mirror and saying this is
what I think I heard you say is and to
ask some clarification sometimes it's
asking a question three or four
different ways and trying to allow those
in the room to truly hear it so I want
to speak more about just the role of
mediation and that is a hope for mine
that there are others who will choose to
engage as invited I was invited by chief
arvo looking horse to serve in this
capacity many years ago and started in
2007 what I saw for the first time as a
white woman with definite privilege
moving to a different state to a
territory that was clearly Dakota and
and these indigenous people and I didn't
know anything about the land part of
that is learning about the people's land
that you're living on and and trying to
do the best you can to walk lightly with
our environment and I recognize that it
is not my role and it is not my position
nor my goal to try to fix anything in
mediation it is not like arbitration or
going through the court system where you
have a judge who makes a decision or an
arbitration where you bring the parties
together and then
there's a statement that's made and
everybody lives with it mediation is a
is an arts of dialogue and bringing
people together to try to find a space
for how do we move this forward but this
is probably the most important thing
that I've learned in the last 10 years
is that peace is not the goal
I believe that peace without justice is
unsustainable and so often people come
in as peacemakers peace builders and
they want to fix the moment and they
will not address the hundreds of years
or whatever the issues are behind the
scenes the players are not at the table
to speak for themselves that could be a
role of a facilitator who can come in
and try to make that a more equitable
conversation not that the mediator says
it's I come from a sports background and
so I think about a referee and back to
hockey that if you have a good referee
you don't see them in the game and that
the game plays and so it is the parties
that are the ones who create the space
to make things happen very quickly and a
brief answer please
you you didn't represent the Lakota
community and in Holyoke has spoken
you know eloquently about you know that
perspective what can you tell us because
they're not here about the feelings in
the law-enforcement community and there
were lots of them on the other side I
mean what were their concerns in this
conflict as somebody who is in the
middle and just like I cannot speak for
Lakota people or those who were at camp
I cannot speak for law enforcement
either and I know that sounds like a
dodge from a question but I must I
cannot speak for them and I think the
biggest lessons are this bringing people
together for those moments as camp
closed trying to find how and this was
led by those who had much more wisdom
than I for them to say how do we move
forward for this next three hours
yeah cross the ocean and and go to
Norway and this event Gamal said that
you do not represent the noosphere
company but rather the mining industry
as a whole and no way seems a lot calmer
at least at this point on the copper
mine proposal Norway is an early
signatory to the UN declaration it has a
careful process to accommodate its
intended to accommodate the rights of
the Sami population and yet you say this
process has become something of a
procedural quagmire going back and forth
lacking quality clarity for your site
how could you improve Norway to enable a
peaceful resolution between what you're
trying to do which is mine copper in a
land where the copper is as you say it's
not anywhere else you can't go somewhere
else for it and accommodate the concerns
of the indigenous communities and
environmental associations that are
allied with them thank you first of all
let me say that I think the two cases
are vastly different what I hear about
Standing Rock tells me that indigenous
people are still vulnerable but these
two cases are set they have different
implications they are set in different
political systems with different
policies call soon
vary the copper mine in the talking
about is plant is an example of Sami
community with the declining and aging
population the mine has strong local
support the mayor tells me it can bring
new optimism and growth and the ground
owner argues that the mining project
will help safeguard the Sami culture and
language locally Norway has among the
world's most strict regulations on
environment health and safety but also
as you mentioned we have rules on how to
take into account
Saamy purposes copper is a key component
in the green technology department as
you said one big challenge for us is the
procedural quagmire or the Sox behind
links hanging Mira in widget this that
this project has happened in it goes
back and forth and I believe it's a
unworthy strategy the Sami Parliament
did not accept a New Eden mineral act as
far as I understand it this is about
three things
it's about indigenous economical
compensation it's about zombies living
outside feed mulch and it's about
consultation and as an industry we don't
have any problems with this in fact I
invite to a discussion how these issues
can be implemented in the mineralized
and I believe you have a common interest
in that we both need the predictability
of a clear act my hope would be to use
this debate to address these challenges
and to forward them to Norwegian
politicians yes we'll go then to the the
obvious response that we will look for
from the president of the Sami
Parliament ie Lika Scootaloo a number of
questions implicit there you were saying
that you like the mining industry are
looking for clarity but that means
something very different for you well we
certainly want to change the mineral act
of Norway but I'm not sure that we want
the same changes as as the mineral
industry but first I would like to say
that also the matter of a standing Rock
and the North Dakota access pipeline is
a matter of solidarity for the sami
people so we recognize your struggles
than your struggles are also our
struggles
and we hope to move forward together I
would like to say that copper mining in
nursery area in Palace nor they in in in
Finnmark is we are opposing strongly the
project of several reasons where the
most important are the disposal of
mining waste into the fjord where the
fish fisheries are and also because it
it's a kind of a land grab of reindeer
herding areas and I feel very strongly
about this because in the same area the
state of norway norwegian authorities
they claim there are too many reindeers
there not enough grazing lands for all
the rangers but they are allowing land
grabbing in the same area last week a
young man from one of the reindeer
herding districts that are are having
trouble with an east nusa mine he was in
the Supreme Court of Norway here in Oslo
defending his right to continue his
reindeer herding because the authorities
are saying to him that he has to
slaughter most of his herd because they
are not enough land for him how can the
same authorities allow continual land
grabbing in in reindeer herding areas
when they are telling us that there is
no room for our reindeer herds of today
it makes no sense to me and and I we
oppose it strongly so it sometimes it
seems like a big conspiracy they are
attacking us from different angles but
what gives me hope is that we are still
here we are still here after hundreds of
years of assimilation policies we are
still here and when it comes to the
community of qalam and the claims that
the copper mining will will make the
Sami language and culture blossom in
this Islamic community and I ask you
show me one indigenous community where
mining has been has made the calculate
in the genus culture and language
blossom give me one example of that I
have tried to research it
specifically you speak in protection of
traditional occupations of Sami reindeer
who husbandry for example what is your
response to the mayor who is referred to
earlier who talked about the fact that
the economy of this region has really
dwindled in in recent decades is
economic development a priority and how
would you like to see economic
development come to the region well I'm
not sure if it's true because the hummer
first area is the region where oil and
the oil and gas industry are booming in
Finnmark and this is the neighboring
village so I don't I don't think it's
it's quite true and the an unemployment
rate in this community is minimal so if
if this community where to where to
where should all the the workers come
from they would have to fly them in from
other parts of the world to work the
mine so I I don't think it's true that
it's the local community and the Sami
culture and and the salmon language
which will benefit from from from the
this project and I would have to say
that if farlis norisse wacom crawls in
communi if they really wanted to fight
for Sami language and culture why did
they refuse to join the administrative
area of Sami language they didn't want
to join up with other Sami communities
to protect the Sami language it's it's
difficult to me for me to understand can
we just get go ahead very briefly we
were included in the response that you
gave so I just want to respond to that
as well that you explained that we were
different than the Sami
and I wanted to just let you know that
we are not we are not any different we
stand in solidarity with the zombies
against mining companies against oil
industries because we are the same we
have experienced the same genocide we
still live in the present day genocide
that is going on and they are not they
are in a very vulnerable indigenous
people and you are actively trying to
make them extinct so the Lakota people
we stand in solidarity with them because
we are the same okay thank you Elizabeth
I feel compelled to give you a very
brief response because but I don't want
to go back and forth too much and then I
want to get to professor of not quickly
but go ahead very shortly and we're not
trying to make them extinct mining is
such was in some areas was was
challenged here we are not in the
backyard not in my backyard business but
we need the minerals and copper is
necessary for the Green transits
transition for electrification etc how
manifest was mentioned yes how many of
us have seen a very positive development
and quarrel soon living next to colleges
first is looking for a similar
development and sees the mine as a
possibility for that let me answer the
question about the position in the field
shortly because when you take out a
mineral like copper there's some
residual and you need to put it
somewhere and this has been decided
putting in the field safely on the
bottom of the field it's in this
particular project it's been considered
that this is the best at least polluting
option and and it this means they have
been through a very thorough
environmental impact association the
deposition is
the copper minerals will stay will be
stable they will be encapsulated by
natural deposition this particular ore
copper is among the cleanest ones in the
world see the position has been tried
locally before and life has come back
also in their substantial knowledge
about it based on several decades of
search practice in the region mines and
just recently an EU Technical Working
Group acknowledged that Norway is doing
this in in a knowledgeable way so
finally on this panel for this round to
Professor or even driving up you're a
legal scholar on Indigenous Affairs you
are in the University of tromsø but
you've also spent time in Indian country
in in the Upper Great Plains of the
United States you were in Standing Rock
before getting to commonalities that you
see between these two conflicts and
where you might see opportunity for some
coming together and crossing the divide
I wonder if you can reconcile some of
what we've been hearing in the dispute
in you know in the in the cross and
project I can say yes thank you for the
question and I can say something about I
bought the mining industry there from a
legal aspect there is of course this
contradiction to the between the
Norwegian Mining Act and the Sami people
there is a few very important point is
the benefit to the indigenous people
which is not ensured in Norwegian a
mineral act there is not a consistent
consultation procedures and when we go
auto-da-fé in mercury right not assure
anything of indigenous people elsewhere
in the country and and of course what is
very much into focus no it is the
pasture of the reindeer herders as the
early casket out of the some a president
told us there was a Supreme Court case
just a week ago where a young reindeer
herder had to defend his land because
the authorities has a program to reduce
numbers of reindeers for sure we cannot
compare it in the way the American the
white Americans reduced the quantity of
buffaloes on the Prairie but in any case
it is method to decrease the level of
reindeer for the Indians people so at
the same time the argument that that
they should take more and more land for
for the mining industry
it doesn't fit it's not as sustainable
development' room for an accommodation
where do you see this proposal going in
the next few months it's likely to be
approved by the Norwegian authorities is
that correct
usually in Norway it's the Norwegian
state in the government who has the last
word so we the Norwegian estate in white
the Sami people to consultation there is
adopted a consultation agreement in 2005
which is rather good or was rather good
at that time but there have been a
development for 12 years after that in
2007 Norway endorsed the UN Declaration
of Rights of Indigenous people who say
that the international standard in such
cases is not consultation but consent
and there have also been a low group who
has presented a bill for consultation
who say that that the standard should be
consent so there is a time for Norway
also to go further when it comes to
dealing with the indigenous people and
to
involve them in the decision making
process process not just inform them and
tell them and ask them to come to the
table and say if you are not agree we
have the last word okay I just wanted to
take us beyond these two to broader
concepts here
dr. Manchu earlier mentioned the
spectacle of electric lines electric
grid lines coming out of indigenous
lands and hydroelectric power going past
the communities and not providing
electricity for the local communities
are there scenarios in which the the
benefits can be more equitably shared
and is that an issue is it an issue of
cultural preservation as well as an
equitable sharing of whatever bounty is
being sought I'll ask you that question
and what I'd like anyone else to also
weigh and especially your new chief at
John but I mean is that an issue is is
it the the bounty sharing that has not
been equitable through history and as it
still perceived as being inequitable and
is that an issue point in the mineral
act who should have a part of the profit
should it go to the land owner or should
it go to the indigenous people who have
their traditional lands in the area
no no rich mineral act they are not in
confirm with ILO 169 who say that
indigenous people should benefit but in
a region stage they defend themselves
saying they give it to the landowner and
the landowner should provide it further
to the indigenous people but in fact we
see that isn't happen so so that's a
it's it's a main issue where the benefit
from the industry should go well would
you like like to see the benefits
distributed that would be more equitable
in your mind non president
[Music]
that is maybe not the most important
question for us at this time because the
most important question for us would be
able to give a consent or not in the
question of if there should be
established mining on sami territory
that is the most important issue for us
to be able to participate in the
decision-making process so any benefit
sharing that would be step 2 3 4 5
further down the line we want a say in
whether a mine should be established or
not and do you see procedurally this is
this evolving in in this particular case
well we said no to the mineral act of
Norway I believe it was in 2006 or 2007
and that's 10 years with an so called
Sox pamellingson amira that Elizabeth
explained about we are hoping to explain
to both soon which authorities and also
to the mineral industry that this is the
mother problem
the biggest problem we haven't agreed on
the legal framework and we will not legi
agree on the legal framework before we
have a right to consent or not to the
mining so I hope that one day then which
authorities will recognize this and
address it in a proper way and we are
have been invited to to the ministry
ministry tomorrow that are dealing with
the mineral industry so maybe that's
kind of a single signal okay chief Chief
John you've talked about Canada being in
the forefront I mean what we're talking
about our our systems in place but the
devil is in the details and the
implementation
and there seems to be a great scarcity
of examples of where the implementation
of some of these elegant declarations
have has actually blossomed talk about
what Canada is doing that gives you hope
I think rightly pointed out what I think
is the essence of what what what is
needed here 60 years ago Lester Pearson
who was then the Prime Minister of
Canada was awarded the Nobel Peace Prize
here in his speech he talked about the
four phases of peace and then one of
these he talked about peace and power
now let me phrase it within the context
of what we're talking about here article
43 of the Declaration the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights speaks about
the 46 standards are the minimum
standards for the survival dignity and
well-being of the world's indigenous
peoples now what does that have to do
with anything well it is it is the
purpose of the Declaration after all so
when I come back to the question of
peace and power the notion of free prior
and informed consent is in embedded in
at least seventeen provisions of the
Declaration and so it's about
decision-making preparing informed
consent is about the ability of
indigenous peoples to make decisions
about their lands and their territories
and resources and in the Declaration it
also says that where development is to
take place in indigenous lands that the
the state must consult and cooperate
with indigenous peoples to obtain their
free prior and informed consent so how
do you how do you make that work how
does so so that's the point I'm that's
the point is it's about a
decision-making process is not about
consultation consultations in the old
standard where you take a piece of paper
and wave it under the indigenous peoples
nose and proceed with the project
so here you have the the Sami Parliament
making decisions on behalf of the Sami
people and you have the state of Norway
the government making decisions of me
after the Norwegian people now what
happens if there's a conflict how do you
resolve that as governments these need
to be as you said you were having
discussions this week so in Canada what
what we have undertaken we have a
constitutional provision that recognizes
in the firm's our rights in 1982 we've
been in the Supreme Court of Canada and
the courts in Canada over 200 times to
find what those seventeen words in the
Constitution mean and and finally the
the courts have got to the point that
consent is a very important issue where
there's where there are deep impacts
that are taking place and I can't think
of anything more important than when
you're impacting on the rights of
indigenous peoples so what we have done
with the Government of Canada and the
provincial government where I come from
is that they have accepted the
declaration to implement in
collaboration with us we're reviewing
the environmental process we're
reviewing the federal national
legislation on the National Energy Board
for pipelines interprovincial pipelines
we're reviewing the environmental
assessment act in Canada we're reviewing
federal legislation on Fisheries that's
important here and we're reviewing
federal legislation on navigable waters
but with our involvement in the process
and so what we talk about is Co
developing legislation not for the
government simply they talk to us and
then proceed as they wish the standards
are changing and the Government of
Canada under this Prime Minister and we
have a Minister of Justice an Aboriginal
woman from the western part where I come
from were absolutely proud of her her
name is Julie Wilson rabo she's in this
very incredibly important place where
she has been able to educate those who
are members of parliament and so here
one of the really big issues is that
there's either racism that exists or
intolerance and at the very best you can
count indifference people who simply
don't care so we have to become our own
advocates ok so you've seen some hint of
political will move in Canada where you
actually might see some implementation
we have did I say very little time we're
almost out of it so I want to offer each
of the panelists maybe thirty Seconds to
sum up and hopefully with an optimistic
note on where you see the political will
to start crossing the divide okay
sharing benefits I think we have
suggested giving it to the Sami
Parliament so if that will be helped let
me also comment on the free inform prior
consent free is fine priorities fine
informed is fine when it comes to
consent as much as far as you can go and
it should be in everything should be any
consideration but I respect to know when
the government has said that the mining
project is not good enough and as long
as the other considerations have been
taken into being considered I think that
we should also respect yes because
copper is necessary we need it for
electrification bringing people out of
poverty
so mining has a role and indigenous
people have role and we want to be
present at the same time and that's
where the discussion should go along how
can we both be present at the same time
professor what can stimulate that
political will to start walking down and
crossing that divide for me also free
prior and informed consent is important
and opposite Elizabet I think the only
important word is consent and and if you
are speaking about the individual if a
weaker party say no she have rights to
say no that's a big focus on that
everywhere it should be the same if it's
in its minority culture protecting their
land say no against intervention from
it's a little bit surprised that this
should be that kind of a big discussion
it's obvious that you should have rights
to say no when somebody inter went in
your land
despite the asymmetry of the power
equation of this it's of course a
question what kind of where the
intervention is done but if it's in the
heart of your motherland or your
traditional land or or as in in in US or
in the Lakota land a tribal land
you should have rights to say no in
cattle oh well we are fighting for our
future as a people and for some kind of
control of our fate so so this is
important to us and we will continue the
struggle we are willing to consult with
the authorities on on in Norway on
better mineral act for the future that
will give us the possibility to to give
consent when
when that is in in question but I think
for the new suitcase we would probably
not have given consent if we were able
to and that is our position when it
comes to the the new city new seed
mining what gives me hope for the future
is of course that the mineral resources
they are in the ground they are not
going anywhere
and they can give it they can be in the
ground for several generations and
forward if we do not have an acceptable
legal framework if we do not have the
right technology to to to extract it
without destroying the environment so so
I'm in that case of the Mystics care for
the future we are not in a hurry
chief 30 seconds important to understand
that indigenous people are not opposed
to development of resources it needs to
be sustainable for sure it's a lot of
times it's where the development is
going to take place and magnitude of
that development how it impacts so
here's the situation as I see we have a
Sami Parliament that makes decisions we
have the Norwegian government that makes
decision so if for example and Canada
makes a decision and we our own Nations
make decisions a lot of people expect
that the government decision and
respected if it's yes or no
but when indigenous governments like the
Sami Parliament for example makes a
decision then people say what gives you
the right to make that decision
and that's really the the incredible
challenge and we fought for a long time
at the United Nations to establish these
standards that allows us to make
decisions about our respective lands
territories and resources and and I
think that's you know that there's a
hope there that that that collaboration
will take place and let me quote let me
quote them justice Rosalia Bella hear
about human rights she noted the
distinction between in many ways we are
a crossroads and human rights justice
and the choices we make will determine
that not only how history will judges
but also what kind of world we will live
on civil rights is about treating
everyone the same Human Rights is about
acknowledging people's differences so
they can be treated as equals and then
she said at the end indifference is
injustice is Incubator it's not what you
stand for with what you stand up for and
then we must never forget how the world
looks to those who are vulnerable and I
would I would put the indigenous peoples
in that category vulnerability in
relation to the power any symmetry that
you talk about so these standards that
the UN declaration
an important balance in mechanism for
indigenous people state relations that's
how we crossed any bite or that's how we
look should look at the divide that the
topic here okay it's definitely what
gives you hope in 30 seconds well you've
seen a beautiful snapshot of what it
means to have dialogue and people in the
room together who have difference of
opinions and trying to move it forward
but this is on the legal frame many of
these questions about how will things
play out in courts how will it play out
in government what happens on the
sidelines though with people who are
grassroots so we're living this when
people come in when law enforcement come
in one of the things that gives me hope
is a conversation that hopefully will
continue about how do we protect those
who are in a spot of medical who are
assisting those when there's a front
line action and who protects the media
are they able to go and can they reports
many things about Standing Rock did not
get reported for many months until there
were injuries and so how did how was
their voice before that happens and how
are the the reporters allowed to come in
to share that message with the world so
creating a framework for keeping medical
media ministry will keep the MS going
mediation legal observers those who are
coming in in the neutral space to help
keep that safe while it works out
through the court system and so I'm
hopeful for that as well okay there are
many things that that would cross the
divide but at the very foundation of it
the American government needs to
recognize that we are a sovereign people
we are capable we are intelligent we are
entitled to be who we are and it's time
for them to acknowledge us as such we
are a nation within what they call their
country and it's time for them to honor
the the laws that they've created it's
time for them to honor the treaties that
they've written and the promises that
they've written on those papers
okay
see if you mentioned that you mentioned
and cited justice Abela on in difference
being the incubator of injustice and a
good part of that might well be the fact
that these issues and these stories are
not widely reported either of them in
the major population centers they're I
was told that that the nasir controversy
is hardly reported or visible in the
Oslo area and the Dakota conflict was
not very widely reported until it really
escalated and I take some responsibility
for that as a as a media person and so
I'm especially thankful to the Nobel
folks for raising or helping raise the
visibility of this issue in the grand
tradition of this institution and I want
to thank all of you for your time as
little as it was and thank you dr.
Manchu thank you so much for coming and
this dialogue will continue tomorrow as
well
you